one of the things that I'm the most
proud about is I didn't go to film
school but I did try to make a movie
when I was 26. I thought it was going to
be the next Jim jar movie I thought it
was going to be this really cool
independent movie that would play the
festivals and I would be this like
critical darling or something but then
finally I I we processed the footage and
I looked at it and I realized I didn't
have what I thought I had not only is it
not that good it's not worth any more of
my time as you can imagine naturally I
was a little depressed but rather than
go to film school I made a movie after
that I was like okay we'll just treat
that that was your film school after
spending three years on something and
and having it turn out to be a big
gigantic failure most of the people
people I know that would have been that
they were like oh okay well I guess this
is just not for me you know and they'd
get a job or something and this is the
point that I'm trying to get at maybe
you try it and maybe you're not right
maybe it doesn't work but that doesn't
mean you're faulty that mean this that
just means that this idea wasn't so what
wasn't so correct or maybe you didn't
know what the [ __ ] you were doing when
you were doing it and but in doing it
you now know more